hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
today we're gonna look at how a high
school jock whose only priority was
partying turn his life around to create
one of the most successful hotel chains
in the world this is the story of Izzy
Sharpe from the Four Seasons Hotel and
the top three lessons that you can learn
from his success
Izzy sharp is a Canadian businessman and
founder and chairman of Four Seasons
Hotel and Resorts sharp didn't have much
stability in his youth and move 15 times
in 16 years he also didn't care much for
school quoting the sharp my life in high
school revolved around sports partying
became my priority that all changed when
Sharpe was accepted into the
architecture program at Toronto's
Ryerson Polytechnical Institute he began
to earn high marks for his creations and
worked for his father building houses
and small apartment buildings yearning
for more at age 29 he founded the Four
Seasons Hotel in 1960 and opened his
first hotel on Jarvis Street in downtown
Toronto
he built a reputation for luxury and
sweating the details which allowed his
business of flourish in 2006 Bill Gates
and Prince Alwaleed bin Talal bought
control of the company for 3.4 billion
dollars
Sharp's current net worth is 540 million
dollars
by sweating the details and by reaching
for his dreams sharp turned his life
around and focused on business instead
of partying he was able to build one of
the most recognized companies in his
industry as a result to help you build
your business here are three action
items that you can learn from easy sharp
action item number one inspire your
employees if you ever want to build a
business beyond yourself you're gonna
have to have a team of people working
with you grow inspired to give their
very best every day sharp didn't become
the leading luxury hotel your in the
world all by himself in the over 50
years he's been in the industry sharp
has developed a unique leadership style
that has encourages employees to vote a
hundred and ten percent of themselves to
the company by creating a working
environment that is built on trust
credibility and integrity Sharpe has
inspired his team to work to realize
their best efforts in the end he
understood that this was a secret
ingredient to helping the company
realize its best results according to
Sharpe we do that first of all by
establishing a meaningful goal an
overriding purpose that most people can
relate to if the goal is clear and the
focus is sharp and constantly reinforced
we unify and energize through a sense of
common purpose and inspires employees to
art and effort action item number two
really service your customers the best
companies are based on happy customers
and repeat business you want to strive
to create an experience where customers
love buying from you and tell their
friends as well in each and every one of
its worldwide locations the Four Seasons
tends to set the top hotel price for the
area it's usually about twenty percent
higher than its closest competitor
how can sharp risks such as pricing
policy he does it by guaranteeing that
his guests get a fail-safe experience so
that a company's eager to pay the extra
fifty dollars to ensure a hassle-free
trip for an executive who might be
working on a 50 million dollar deal
according to sharp our competitors
interpreted luxury chiefly as dazzling
architecture and decor but how important
is that to our customers they're mostly
executives often under pressure
fighting jet lag stressed in the clock
we decided to redefine luxury
a service
action item number great live by the
golden rule the golden rule is to treat
people as you would like to be treated
it's not only a great way to achieve
happiness as an entrepreneur it's also a
highly profitable strategy driving force
behind sharp success has been his desire
to treat for seizes employees with the
same love of respect that they in turn
are expected to give their guests the
success of this policy has shown itself
not only in terms of customer happiness
but also employee engagement and
satisfaction for years the Four Seasons
has been the only Canadian company to
land on Fortune's magazine's list of the
best hundred companies to work for in
the US according to sharp we aim to
treat others as we would like to be
treated ourselves enforcing our credo
was the hardest part and senior managers
who couldn't or wouldn't live by a who
weeded out within a few years we hire
for attitude want people who like other
people and are therefore more motivated
to serve them compliments we can teach
attitude is ingrained so remember
inspire your employees really service
your customers and live by the golden
rule to finish up this video I wanted to
share one of my favorite true stories
about easysharp and some of his best
quotes in 1967 one Four Seasons employee
went to the extreme in demonstrating the
kind of service Sharpe was trying to
encourage a bellboy for the hotel Roy
diamond discovered that a dignitary
guest had left his briefcase behind
after checking out the guest soon called
from Washington stating that the
contents of the briefcase were essential
for an upcoming meeting feeling
responsible Diamond bought a plane
ticket at his own expense and personally
delivered the briefcase to the former
guests
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the masters I hope
you enjoyed I'd love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment below and please give
the video a thumbs up stay tuned for the
next episode